chimera is equipped with an array of
structure analysis resources that allow
you to analyze the protein environment
around a ligand visualize interactions
within the protein and more
here we have the myoglobin structure 1
mbo which contains a heme group as shown
to analyze the protein environment
around this heme group we start by
selecting it under the non-standard
residues category
now we can select all residues within
the vicinity of this heme group by going
to select by zone
in the zone parameters we see that all
atoms and bonds within five angstroms of
the current selection will be selected
you can of course adjust these
parameters as needed to fully include
residues that only fall partially into
the five angstrom range check this box
here upon clicking ok
the desired vicinity is selected
we can now color this region by element
by going to actions
color and by element
and once we clear the selection
we can see the coloration clearly
we can also use chimera's analysis
resources to measure the distance
between two atoms such as the iron of
heme and the coordinating nitrogen of
the proximal histidine residue to do
this we start by selecting both atoms
using control shift and left click
then under tools
structure analysis
we open up the distances panel when we
click create we see the distance
displayed in the panel
and in the graphics window
in addition to measuring distances you
can also visualize hydrogen bonding
interactions within the structure
to do this go to tools structure
analysis and find h bond
if we apply the default settings
all the hydrogen bonds within the
structure are found
to find all hydrogen bonds involving a
specific component such as the serine
hydroxyl
first select your component of choice
using control and left click and then
run the hydrogen bond search again
make sure to turn on this setting here
to restrict your search to the selected
component
now only hydrogen bonds involving the
serine hydroxyl are shown
here we have the hemoglobin structure 4
hhb we can use chimera to compare this
structure with the related myoglobin
structure that we have been analyzing to
import the myoglobin structure we go to
file fetch by id and type in 1mbo
the structure then enters the graphics
window but it doesn't seem to be
aligning with any of the hemoglobin
chains
to solve this problem we can go to tools
structure comparison and select
matchmaker
then we choose our reference structure
the hemoglobin and the structure to
match the myoglobin
when we click apply we see the myoglobin
aligning with chain d of the hemoglobin
with hemoglobin chains a b and c deleted
we can now get a better look at the
overlay although there are some
positional differences such as the alpha
helices overall there is much similarity
between the two structures and as we see
here the positions of the key histidine
residues around the heme group are well
conserved between the two structures as
is the position of the heme group itself